[Music]
the rest in the tour is going to be
amazing just going to get better and
better will the show come back will you
bring the show back will you follow
while you're traveling will we see you
on the road while you're touring cuz
you're going back to Europe for the
first time in a long time
I mean never say never but and I did
have a really good time somebody showing
there were a lot of real moments that
were that were that were cool but um
like I said never say never but I'm not
gonna say yes right you know what the
next season could be about you and
that's gonna be about you know you know
it would be about y'all look it would
only I would only do it if it could be
about you Kevin and that's it that's all
I'm gonna say tonight thinking somehow
[Music]
all right when will we finally get your
new music a lot of people are waiting a
lot of people excited when we get that
different very soon because I have to go
on the road and I have a lot of things
to do so the sooner the better